let's make way for Jack Nicklaus who
joins us on the program good morning
jack how are you hey Dan how you doing
where are you right now I'm at home I've
been here for about three and a half
weeks in the house are you what are you
doing to kind of keep your mind going
I'm calling that I know I had to tell
you Jack not today call me tomorrow here
let's let's do it anniversary I might I
think I watched Caddyshack about four
times and a couple of times and you know
a couple a few good Ben I think I've
seen that a couple of times I mean you
know you've watched watch a little bit
of everything
is there a putting green or a chipping
area that you go out and can you do that
well I can but I don't you know I don't
I've got I've got a little artificial
fighting green out and back which I've
had for about seven or eight years I
don't think I've ever had a foot on it
really well I you know I don't once I
stopped playing golf I just sort of you
know stopped doing that stuff you know
you know this is the anniversary if I
think from your 72 master's championship
but of all the championships which one
do you get the most questions about well
I think obviously 86 mm-hmm I mean I
think that 75 was a pretty pretty good
year in the Weiskopf and Miller coming
down the stretch that was that that was
a heck of a tournament but at 86 is the
one where I wasn't supposed to win and
nobody expected me win including me and
I found lightning in the bottle and it
works but also when you go out and you
just post a score and then you're
waiting because normally you're usually
in that final twosome you know the
difference between actually being out
there competing it with somebody or
waiting to see what happens how
agonizing was that for you well you know
I think that when we started the day I
was four shots back and I had eight
players in front of me and I thought
that was reasonable and my son Steve had
called me in the morning and he said
what do you think pops and I said well
Steve
at I think 66 left i-65 will win he says
exact score I have in mind go shoot it
so I had a you know sort of a little bit
of a feel the first Jackie was on the
bag and we we got going we didn't get a
very good start and we were sort of just
even through eight holes then i birdied
the night hold on birdied danbury's 11
you know sort of got a little enthusiasm
then I'd bogey 12:00 at the end of
turnaround birdied 13 of course then i
eagled 15 birdied 16 and birdied 17 and
that's when I got into the lead of the
tournament so once I got into the lead
of the tournament I finished and all of
a sudden you know it looks like I've got
a shot to win I went into the Jones
cabin and set there and was sitting in a
couch and watching watch Tom Kyte miss
his putt at the last hole then I watched
seve or nut Chevy uh a semi had already
passed because he hit the water 15 but
the Greg Norman start to birdie you know
he bade me I think four or five birdies
in a row and I'm sitting on the couch
and I said yeah he's making too many
birdies so me sitting there so I got up
and walked around behind the couch sit
up and watch the last two holes
birdied 17 I said whoops I'm gonna stay
here though innit but you know you know
yours nothing you can do about it all
you're sitting there doing is watch it
and that's not usually bit by my mode my
motors you're right being in one of the
last couple of groups and playing for
right down to the end but this time I
was sitting there watching the last few
groups and I'll tell you that's a little
harder what did you say from 1986
masters what did I want from save say
like clubs you know your plaid pants
well you know oddly enough the only I
have every single Golf Club that I ever
won a major with except one and you can
guess what that is that's that big
putter I think I know where it is I
think it's sittin in the Billy scan and
the tennis players living room at home I
think I gave it to him one time to play
I think it's a in this bag and but I
know I got every other club that I ever
played with and that's the one I'm
missing so I miss
that I had the clubs but from from that
tournament you know I realized that you
know if you put your mind to something
and you're I was relatively well
prepared for the tournament even though
I was not in the peak of my game and all
of a sudden I got to the last nine holes
and I remembered how to play and I
remembered what it took to finish a golf
tournament and when you do that that is
so much fun because all of a sudden I'm
sitting okay I got to do this I got to
do that I got I can't do this I can't do
that my abilities allow me to do this my
abilities won't allow me to do this you
know and all of a sudden I it all came
together and I finished the tournament
and that that was what I like I came
away with is that you know I could still
do something if you really put your mind
to it but did you know you had lost that
to then have to remember to get it back
well I think I think everybody loses
their I mean if you I know it you know
your skills start to erode or you get
into a certain age and I was having more
fun watching my kids play football and
basketball and whatever and so I wasn't
working as hard at it but the skills
were there they were just hidden and so
I had to go find them I really wasn't
worried about pulling them out until all
of a sudden I got myself in contention
and I needed to and I did so that was
that was really very rewarding for me
talking to Jack Nicklaus it was on this
day 1972 that he won his fourth of six
green jackets and you you get to take
them off site for a little while do you
get to take them off for a year and then
they have to go back to Augusta is that
how the green jackets work well I never
took mine off the site I know that I
remembered Gary Player but first time he
won his he got a call from cliff Roberts
and and he said cliff said to him he
said Kerry we can't find your green
jacket you know where it is
he says this mr. Roberts I've got it
right here in South Africa he said well
you know it's not supposed to leave the
property he says well you can come get
it any time you have
but anyway we got a big kick out of that
but you know I never took mine off the
property and oddly enough I tell you a
quick story I never got my own green
jacket the first year I won I got a they
put a 46 long on me and I'm about a 43
regular and the next year I the next
year I came back there was a jacket my
locker it was Tom Dewey's jacket
former governor in New York and his
jacket fit me perfect and they never
gave me a green jacket so I worked I
wore Tom do his jacket for the next 25
years and finally in 1998 they were
going to do a thing between 16 and 17 a
water fountain but you know story about
it and I was sitting down with Jack
Stevens was a chairman then he said I
told him the story I've never been
presented a green jacket either what he
said all these years everybody gets
green giants you never got one I said no
I've never had a green jacket and he
says so anyway I went home for the
weekend and came back there was a note
in my locker you will go to the Pro Shop
and you will be fit for your green
jacket so the first green jacket I ever
had was 1998 that's amazing amazing what
do you think Augusta is going to look
like play like in November I think
you'll play alright I think the fairways
will be the question I don't know what
they'll do I don't know ones I'll reseed
them early or wait until after the
tournament to oversee them because a
fair the Bermuda fairways would play
beautifully in November the the greens
will be fine and won't be a problem to
Grange obviously you won't have the
color throughout the alka course but if
they can get the fairways good I think
the golf course to play fine they're
going to have shorter days there's a lot
more daylight in April than there is in
November so the Sun will be a little bit
of a different problem probably probably
November not that much when you know I
think I'll have a good turban I don't
think it's a problem I'm delighted that
they're going to have it I didn't think
they'd be able to get it in I thought
with all the other tournaments and all
the other commitments of the tour has to
put it together it was tough though they
put they're putting all the major
tournaments in and they kept getting the
British Open cancelled but it's I think
it's great that they're going to add
getting the masters in in normal times
could could you just show up and play at
Augusta if you wanted to I mean not the
tournament but just show up to play the
course any any former champion can come
and play anytime he wants but he can't
bring yes now Arnold and I were the only
two regular members of the course we
were invited to join some time during
our career and I can take guests and
play anytime I want to but I guess I'm
the only one now but it's it's just
really neat to be able to have some
friends and say hey how would you like
to go up to Guster for the weekend you
know not many up what they've got to be
able to go well I got to stay in the
Eisenhower cabin and stay overnight
there and you just walk over to the
grill room and it was just a wonderful
experience because nobody was there and
the caddies were wonderful they're
betting on you I got traded on the first
tee by a caddie thank you it was just it
was fun and the most fun I had was when
I went to 12 because 12 as an amateur we
play it the same yardage that the pros
do and when you see when you're up there
and you go it doesn't look that
difficult and then all of a sudden I'm
in raised Creek after hitting an 8-iron
I go yeah I get it
you know it the optical illusion of it's
beautiful but it's incredibly
challenging there do you have great
memories of 12 oh yeah
the first year I played there I had a
storm of so named Roger McManus and
Roger hit hit a shot that he hit that
went through the green and I think Roger
hit a 6-iron well you know I said well I
don't wanna hit it through the rain so I
hit 7-iron and the ball ballooned right
up in the air and I made it about
halfway across the creek and I said
whoops and so I figured out that you
don't want to be throwing the ball real
high in there you want to keep it
underneath the trees as you can and for
some reason the whole place much better
left to right than it does right to left
right to left the ball goes across the
green in the narrow side of it and the
green sort of works this way left to
right a little bit away for
and so a left-to-right shot coming up
the Greens works in better it seems to
work with a win better but I think I may
have fitted in there another time during
my career but it's I didn't it in there
very much after that first time you
learn what you did wrong and then you go
out and do in practice rounds and try to
replicate what you were doing and just
sort of sit there and say okay okay I
can't do that I can do this and you
learn how to play it but it's a it's
probably still I like I considered
probably the scariest part reading golf
but you know you have all the fully Amin
you have all the growth there though
Jack that's what it like it it it makes
it seem like it's an optical illusion of
it hey that's beautiful
and then you realize no you got to you
got to put it on a small green you don't
want to go long with the bunker you go
short it goes into the creek the wind as
you're looking on 13 the wind above 13 T
you just came off 11 with the flag and
you look at that I'm going oh my god you
could over process the information here
everybody over processes it and you
decided you got to be a little bit lucky
you got to sort of watch the wind I
don't know and I'm not sure which when
you watch but you got to watch it so
does that you don't get caught in the
gust
how many presidents have you played with
oh not that many I supposed to play with
ice an hour and he got sick one day and
he ended up like going around in an
exhibition with Arnold in May and then I
played Jerry Ford I played I played a
lot of rounds of golf with Jerry Ford we
played we played at BB together quite
often in that in the Crosby and I played
I played quite a few rounds with Clinton
just played a few holes with hwa-- hwa--
Busch not played with George we've
scheduled a place several times they
never have made it and of course I
played I played quite a bit of golf
Sistrunk now at that of that group can
you can you rank who's the best
president you played with well they're
all good presidents I mean I think
Trump's the best player okay
jump in Sepang quite nicely he's he's
pretty long he's got a nice golf swing
he does her he plays golf much the way I
do now he doesn't really care about a
score he goes out and hits the ball if
he hits it out of places okay just give
me another one and you know he doesn't
hold up play plays fast he he just ate
must have fun
much like HW he was not a scorer either
he just tried to he want to play around
the golf course I understand that young
George is a single-digit player and is
pretty good player now but he's we have
an innovative of together Clinton could
have been a good player he has a nice
golf swing you know I just I don't think
he ever he was he was one who just you
know it took so many Mulligan's do you
know which is all right here
that was way to play they had fun and so
and but Jerry Jerry Ford was a very
serious golfer he he he was he was about
a 13 and he played to a 13 82 84 85 and
he he grant he was a grinder and he just
but he just he just loved he loved
playing golf is Chris he is an athlete
and he was a good athlete and he just he
just loved to play I leave you with this
of all the years and I've talked to you
and everything I've read about you i I
just realized that the mascot of your
high school up was Upper Arlington is
that right
the Golden Bears right yeah that's right
is that where the nickname came from
well it sort of came from there in 1961
the year before I turned pro or the fall
when I turned pro the following Don
Lawrence with an Auburn aged in
Australia wrote an article about not me
mark McCormick was down there and he
called me a company Golden Bear in the
article that was large and blond at the
time and so first contract I had was
with the Revere sportswear out of Boston
and it was they were looking for an
emblem and we kept going through all
kinds of things trying to find it some
of a crest rat emblem and you know I
said hey guys you know I like the Golden
Bear I was a golden bear in high school
I've been a golden bear all my life why
don't we just stay a golden bear and
that's how it happened
wow I did not know that I forgot all
about Upper Arlington and the golden
bears it's great to hear from you thanks
for sharing and hope hope you don't have
to go back to Caddyshack and stripes any
time soon and maybe add something else
to your TV repertoire if they put
anything I can figure out how to work
that way oh no that's what your mind
kids for all I know I'm sorry I'm a
electronic idiot you know I am terrible
but anyway we Barbara and I've been
Washington we turn on a TV series and we
watch about one series I don't like that
okay so we're trying other one which I
don't like that it's okay so you know we
keep settling but anyway we're we're
happy we're getting through it and what
we're doing all right
thank you jack great to talk to you we
appreciate it as always okay Dan that is
Jack Nicklaus